let's move on now to Kelly Ripa because
she's calling out the outrageous sexism
and revealing her unglamorous life
behind the scenes from her early days at
live
it was definitely a place where I was
expected to be grateful and to
appreciate my job without creating a
fuss and without any self-advocacies
these were just basic things that a
person might ask for one of those things
an office but Kelly says instead of
getting one in her fourth year at live
quote I was working in the Janitor's
Closet with a desk she also didn't have
her own bathroom which became tricky
while pregnant we have a studio audience
like 250 people I have to host the show
and I'm still waiting in line to use the
bathroom I wanted to give up I think it
was the camaraderie of the women that I
worked with there that really kept me
going
another reason she stayed money her
salary reportedly around 20 million and
in varieties the power of women issue
out tomorrow the 52 year old says quote
I don't think they wanted to pay me I
think they had to pay me I was trying to
walk out the door and close it behind me
I try to remind every woman I work with
as much as possible know your worth and
go after what your worth is Kelly says
she doesn't Harbor any resentment for
her co-host although we know her
relationship with Regis Philbin did not
come naturally to expect two people from
such different Generations
to have some sort of weird forced
friendship is a very strange thing to
put on one person and I was vilified
Kelly's heavy Mark takes over as co-host
on live April 17th but she didn't
initially pitch him as Ryan Seacrest's
replacement the idea of Mark becoming
the co-host was brought up to us by the
network by ABC and then I got on board
kind of quickly because they showed me
all the pros there were not really any
cons although I if I'm being completely
honest my son Michael was a little upset
that he was not considered for the job
over mark
foreign